the man stands in the same place he's
been for the past 13 years writing out
his life story for everyone to witness
and yes when they realized what it
actually is they'll see me hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to markiplier makes fanfiction I
am your host of sorts although I may be
donning this outfit I will not be
hosting you today no we will be writing
for you introducing introducing Tyler
he's a man who stands alone riding in a
lofty lighthouse on the side of the sea
also introducing Ethan who's been
writing in his basement alone for years
his grandchildren never called but when
he makes this book what's it called
horses presidents keep working up he
finishes this book and take the world by
storm
Twilight whatever killing games but
we're not just here to write fanfiction
for you we're here to write fanfiction
for us so what we need from you is a
suggestion for an idea wait was your boy
your grandma character Thompson bad
technology device do you sell the device
no you think while we're waiting for
your responses let me give you a little
taste of the history of writing back in
the year 1922 the typewriter was
invented by a man named Yorkshireman
von der beek and he looked at his piece
of paper and pen and was like this is
just ridiculous who could who would who
should and he cried out to the heavens
and the devil's and he said please lord
give me a sign
how do I need us into the Age of
Enlightenment
the typewriter fell from the sky [ __ ]
hamster like a giant what happens on the
tour bus stays in the tour bus elaborate
I think that we should do the tour bus
all in favor of the tour bus say aye
hey alright it's decided then
so we should explain Howard thanks
grandma who wants to write first that's
not an answer should we just get down
yes Ethan mrs. Thompson
will have the honor of going first so
here's how it works
Ethan is gonna start out by reading for
three minutes straight as much as he can
and then when he's done he will read me
the last sentence that he wrote and then
I will write for three minutes and then
Tyler will write for three minutes using
the last sentence that I wrote we won't
know what each other writes until we
play begins
are you ready mrs. Nesbitt Thompson oh
I'm ready
I can't delete if I make a mistake I
have to keep going I am in such
concentration typewriter down okay all
right all right well that was inspiring
to look at so here's the question do I
have to read you what it says
exactly lots of last sentence yeah
exactly exactly what there's no way I
could be in dang 2d once more
dang Diddy okay great is it hard to
concentrate yeah shut up
[ __ ] oh no I made so many mistakes on
that one because it's complete sentence
if I wrote any more I wouldn't be good
see my issue when I was doing it was I
wanted to write fast but then I wasn't
pressing the keys hard enough so then it
just wouldn't go and I was like oh and
then it would miss letters so it looks
like it was a different word so I would
complete that this is your sentence are
you ready Mar talk to a tea tow meant I
the Sieber hot side
what all right good luck
something break oh I thought sup I
thought so piece of metal just finish
the seats the typos are killing us
killing you maybe I'm thriving off of
typos eat and smirked in our smirked i
responds to his bet two full words I'm a
little bit afraid because I had this
premonition that whenever we speak these
out lab those things written on paper
are gonna come to life bounine what do
you that Saul I've ever seen on the
Internet
what I don't read it that often but
that's all I see is you already ready
you you can feel for like hours at a
time but you can't just put that stream
of consciousness on paper
listen no it just flows out of my body
and I can't translate it to my fingers
[Music]
there you go okay ready
you know but go ahead
let's nam let this get boot of Han remit
are so this why we're still her actually
I've written plenty of short stories
novels written in not one I would like
to surrender the rest of us to him so I
don't get a stupid sentence like lasagna
at the end there a full moon
there was Nam time the had to beat this
fool with teehee palpable of what there
was Nam time none time the had to beat
this fool with T he love I can read it
clear put the pieces where they're
supposed to go so you're saying like
anyone got a child to put whoever made
this is a [ __ ] idiot oh no whoever
made this is dead I'm gonna start
writing out letters
to people instead of texting I'm gonna
get a pigeon surgeons are extinct what
yeah you didn't know that I thought I
think pigeon could be a carrier pigeon
if you drain it mm-hmm no carrier
pigeons were a specific breed why anyway
so how'd it go how is it ready I think
pretty good this beast was of another
time period in earth from which it know
how now return done okay and they did we
don't really have any context yeah it's
fine don't worry about it got it hmm
that was their lethal miss stocky what's
the title of the book I was trying to
remember that decide that at the end
that's the end okay that is good no man
the ending is the title no that's the
end well no no no you can't type
anything yeah that is the end mm-hmm
it's done manuscripts we're going to be
doing a dramatic reading of this and you
will see just how dramatic it gets when
we start the story of what happens on
the tour bus stays on the tour bus
Plus hot horrible bus they thought that
would Nev escape it the boys had been in
on the bus freedom what freedom there
was no freedom Mark's sister and people
right to be on that bus anyway
dream that Ethan was going to die mark
even I think you're in grave danger of
death today please be our full F the bus
Ethan what there's no way I could be in
dang titty like I said there is not way
because it is too big you fool cried
Ethan
but then Tyler realized the grievous
error that he had commit would he had no
pants mark looked longingly into eaten
and Tyler's soul as he drank their
essence wit father Mark said I am
feeling Randy and blood is fleeing
Ethan started the Rosses of changing
Tyler flexed his mighty girth on till
all that remained was manage mark this
opportunity to mint I the Sieber outside
the Sieber was looming in the tour bus
whilst sitting on a passing car Marv was
fascinated by the Sieber and thus
entranced his associate to whom he was
speaking but in described G be the sea
bird to the bus Marv lost to for AK of
what was truly his purpose the love for
which he has for his friends which he
would not
like to express physically some are
Goreski to men's race and whisper in his
ear seductively it sounds pretty sexual
easy birth I response to his betta fault
words the smirk was best milk that ever
had given his smile was grat his tan
shone through his lips mark you put
those away I won't allow you to take
this spotlit away from me a guy Ethan
don't make this about you mice me ha
always been and always will be better
than ours my father will be a hair rig a
boot miss Tyler guys guys guys let's
numb lit this get boot of Han room it'd
our schools why we're still her lasagna
5 hey he boys are membered that there
was Stouffer's lasagna in the freezer
the boys jumped for joy and waved their
respective Pinay they danced and waked
deed with jubilant patience yeah their
pop the weasel and they feasted on the
flesh of their fall and food but then
they remembered the sea bear oh no said
Ethan judge gee you said Tyler mumbly
come please there was a long time the
had to beat this fool with TV power of
love with the TV power mara and friends
hugged and chanted wealth I a circle
which I was the monster to cease and
stat slurring his speech
shaking and chanting and dancing shook
the bus to the point that the driver
lost control
ms latvia went everywhere as the bus
crashed down a slope blaming somehow on
his wheels move and bar was enough to
see the monster had escaped from the TV
power or of friendship this beast was of
another time period and earth from which
it knew now returned the Beast looked on
this tit in fashion and he poked one
aisle breathy breath breath Monster Mash
if you are rouille and the teeth then
show me a sign he'll this ebay that was
the lethal miss daaé from the bee had
now passed so that now person could tell
the story of the tour bus and the attack
and occurrences that occurred so from
that point it was unmistakeably declared
and then that's the end
there you have it it's been an honor to
write for you it's been an honor to be
here among such esteemed writers such as
the Annie
thank you Amy Thank You Catherine and
thank you and as always we will see you
in the next video bye